THEIR VIRTUE SIGNALING IS A
FRAUD.
>> REPUBLICAN CONGRESSWOMAN, A
MEMBER OF THE HOUSE HOMELAND
SECURITY COMMITTEE IS HERE.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS
HYPOCRISY?
THE MIGRANT FLIGHTS COMING IN
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT INTO
NEW YORK STATE AND WESTCHESTER
COUNTY, NO ONE WOULD HAVE KNOWN
ABOUT THOSE INSTEAD OF THE
REPORTING OF THE "NEW YORK
POST."
>> THE HEIGHT OF HYPOCRISY.
YOU THINK ABOUT THE 78 FLIGHTS
ALONE THAT CAME INTO
JACKSONVILLE, FLORIDA IN THE
DEAD OF THE NIGHT THAT TOOK A
FREEDOM OF INFORMATION REQUEST
BY MEMBERS OF CONGRESS TO GET
THAT FROM THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
YET 50 ILLEGALS GET FLOWN INTO
THE PLAYGROUND OF THE RICH AND
FAMOUS, HOME OF BARACK OBAMA,
ALL OF  SUDDEN THEY'RE OUTRAGED.
OBAMA WAS THE AUTHOR OF THE
KIDS IN CAGES.
NOW THEY'RE ON THEIR FRONT
DOORSTEP AND OH MY GOODNESS, WE
HAVE TO GET THE MILITARY
INVOLVED.
I HAVE A NOD TO GOVERNOR
DESANTIS FOR HIS SHREWD ACUMEN
AND THE COURAGE TO TAKE THE
FIGHT TO THOSE ON THE LEFT AND
THOSE THAT CHOOSE TO IGNORE AND
VIRTUE SIGNAL BUT ALSO TO YOU
AND THE ENTIRE FOX TEAM YOU
GUYS ARE THE ONLY NETWORK
COVERING THIS EPIC CRISIS THAT
WE HAVE BEEN FACING.
NO OTHER NETWORK HAS TOUCHED IT.
THEY DON'T WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE $2 MILLION THAT EL PASO HAS
ALLOCATED AND THE 25 CHARTER
BUSES THEY ARE SENDING TO
SANCTUARY CITIES.
IT IS ONLY WHEN GOVERNOR ABBOTT
AND DESAPTIS THAT IT -- SAME ON
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION FOR
IGNORING THE PUBLIC HEALTH,
HUMANITARIAN AND NATIONAL
SECURITY CRISIS THAT HE HAS
CREATED AT OUR SOUTHWEST BORDER.
>> THE "NEW YORK POST" HAS A
COUPLE OF OP-EDS WITH HEADLINES
LIKE THIS.
WITH MARTHA'S VINEYARD MELTDOWN
MAYBE DEMS WILL FINALLY
UNDERSTAND ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION
PROBLEMS AND ALSO THIS.
DEMS ARE UPSET THAT DESANTIS
HAS MADE THEM LOOK IN THE
MIRROR ON MIGRATION.
AND THE FACT THAT JUST TO USE
ONE EXAMPLE OF MANY, THE PRESS
SECRETARY CALLS MOVING MIGRANTS
TO OTHER PLACES IN THE UNITED
STATES CRUEL.
WHAT'S CRUEL IS LAYING A
FOUNDATION WHERE HUMAN
TRAFFICKERS AND DRUG
TRAFFICKERS PROFIT FROM HUMAN
MISERY AND SUFFERING AND EVEN
DEATH, WHETHER IT'S THE
HUNDREDS, AS THE UNITED STATES
AND GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT
MENTIONED THIS.
THE UNITED NATIONS SAID OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER IS THE MOST
DEADLY IN THE WORLD.
HUNDRED OF MIGRANTS HAVE DIED.
51 WHO DIED TRAPPED IN A
TRACTOR TRAILER.
THEN ALSO THE THOUSANDS UPON
THOUSANDS, TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS WHO DIE FROM FENTANYL
POISONING.
WHERE IS THE OUTRAGE FROM THE
LEFT?
>> THEY LIVE IN AN ALTERNATE
REALITY.
THEY DON'T SEE THE CRUELTY AT
THE SOUTHWEST BORDER BECAUSE
THEY REFUSE TO GO THERE.
THEY WANT TO LIVE IN THE
ALTERNATE REALITY WHERE THEIR
OPEN BORDER POLICY IS SOMEHOW
HUMANE.
IT IS INHUMANE.
I CAN TELL YOU FIRSTHAND HAVING
BEEN THERE FIVE TIMES THAT IS
WHAT'S INHUMANE ARE THE CARTELS
THAT VICIOUSLY GANG RAPE YOUNG
GIRLS AS YOUNG AS 9 YEARS OLD.
I HAVE SEEN IT MYSELF.
THE HUMAN TRAFFICKING, THE OVER
100,000 FAMILIES THAT HAVE LOST
LOVED ONES BECAUSE OF THE
FENTANYL THAT HAS BEEN PEDDLED
AND TRAFFICKED ACROSS THE
BORDER.
THE ONLY THING THAT IS INHUMANE
AND CRUEL IS THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION'S OPEN BORDER
POLICIES AND THAT'S WHAT IS
GOING TO CHANGE.
AMERICANS WILL NEVER FORGET THE
OPEN BORDER POLL SEALS THAT
HAVE SIMULTANEOUSLY CREATED A
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS,
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS AND
NATIONAL SECURITY CRISIS
ALLOWING MEMBERS OF THE
INTERNATIONAL TERRORIST WATCH
LIST TO COME ACROSS THIS BORDER
AND GANG MEMBERS, DRUGS HAVE
DESTROYED OUR NATIONAL SECURITY
IN THAT RESPECT.
WE WILL NOT LET THEM FORGET IT.
>> BEFORE WE GO, CALIFORNIA
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM IS ALSO
CALLING OUT RON DESANTIS AND
GOVERNOR ABBOTT CALLING ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
CONSIDER KIDNAPPING CHARGES.
HE TWEETED THIS.
I'M FORMALLY REQUESTING THE
D.O.J. BEGIN AN IMMEDIATE
INVESTIGATION INTO THESE
INHUMANE EFFORTS TO USE KIDS AS
POLITICAL PAWNS.
IT SEEMS LIKE THAT GAVIN NEWSOM
TENDS TO WAKE UP TO THESE
ISSUES WHEN HE CAN USE IT AS A
POLITICAL WEAPON.
BUT NOT BEFORE.
>> IT'S KIND OF CONCERNING, THE
OBSESSION THAT CALIFORNIA
GOVERNOR NEWSOM HAS WITH
FLORIDA GOVERNOR RON DESANTIS.
I THINK THERE IS MAYBE A HINT
OF JEALOUSY IN THE FACT WE ARE
OEF THE FREEST STATE IN THE
NATION AND OUR EDUCATION IS TOP
IN THE NATION AND THEY ARE
FALLING AT THE BOTTOM OF EVERY
BAD LIST, CALIFORNIA IS.
IT'S A VERY STRANGE DYNAMIC.
HE SHOULD EVEN TALK TO HIS OWN
IN LAWS WHO FLED TO THE FREE
STATE OF FLORIDA.
I THINK GOVERNOR NEWSOM WOULD
BE BEST FOCUSING ON THE ISSUES
IN HIS BACKYARD, HOMELESSNESS,
DRUG CRISIS, PEOPLE FLEEING SO
MUCH SO HE HAS TO RUN ADS IN
OTHER STATES TELLING PEOPLE TO
COME HOME.
HE HAS TO FOCUS ON HIS OWN
ISSUES BEFORE HE COMES AT MY
GOVERNOR RON DESANTIS.
>> I'LL ALSO POINT OUT AT LEAST
ONE COUNTY, I BELIEVE IT'S
SANTA CLARA COUNTY IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA, IS DISTRIBUTING
NARCAN IN ALL THE HIGH SCHOOLS
BECAUSE OF THE FEAR AND DANGER
RELATED TO FENTANYL OVERDOSES
IN OUR HIGH SCHOOLS AMONG
TEENAGERS.
>> ABSOLUTELY HEARTBREAKING.
AS A PARENT I CAN'T EVEN
IMAGINE HAVING MY HIGH SCHOOLER
COME HOME AND SAY I GOT NARCAN
TODA